oh good excellent well done okay welcome
to this joint audit and standards
committee I am councilor Dave Muller and
I am chairing the meeting today may I
first of all remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones turned off when not in use
but you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
ensure your mobile phones are on silent
or Switched Off and additionally we will
be using the e-voting for this meeting
on the modern.gov app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and same
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
I now like to introduce the officers we
have John Snell the corporate manager
for internal audit
and we have if the alley the interim
monitoring officer and we have our
committee services staff Beth Claire and
Alicia with us as well can I move to the
agenda please
item one apologies for absence and
substitutions man receives chair thank
you very much item two to receive
Declarations of pecunery and
non-pecuniary interest by members
do we have any
not at all thank you very much item
three to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme none received
sure thank you and therefore we move on
to item 4 Jack 2145 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 30th
of January 2023
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
okay could I have a proposer please
councilor Eber and a secondary councilor
Huron thank you I now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please and I will sign the minutes after
that's been confirmed thank you thank
you chair that way is now in progress
thank you
councilor Davies may I take you very
verbally
that is eight breaks for one abstention
that is carried
thank you very much indeed okay item
five questions by the public none
received thank you and item six
questions by counselors none received
chair okay thank you so we move on to
item seven which is Jac stroke 21 stroke
46 managing the risk of Fraud and
Corruption annual report 22-23 I would
now like to invite the corporate manager
for internal audit Jon Snow to introduce
the report to the committee
thank you John
thank you chair good afternoon members
um so this report that you have in front
of you outlines the current Arrangements
in place across both councils to help
ensure there is a a proactive corporate
approach uh to deterring preventing and
detecting fraud and Corruption and it
also outlines and details some of the
proactive work that we've undertaken
throughout the years and the return
audit team
I think it's important just to point out
that while it's it's not the primary
role of internal audit function to
detect field it does have a role in
providing an independent insurance on
the effectiveness on the processes they
put in place by management
to detect and mitigate fraud and where
necessary internal award it would be
required to investigate the causes of
Fraud and perhaps allegations of fraud
itself
so how do we achieve this well this is
actually done through the internal audit
plan which is the next paper that I'll
be presenting to you it provides an
allowance for internal audit to
undertake both proactive and reactive
work in terms of counter fraud work
the planning process is further
supported by what's called a fraud risk
register this contains a list of areas
where I and fellow corporate managers
believe that the councils could be
susceptible to areas of fraud
the register also helps managers to
focus on suitable internal controls to
mitigate and subsequent risks
you'll see that from the report that a
lot of our work particularly for this
chair has concentrated on raising
awareness across the councils and here's
a list of examples particularly around
the raising of money laundering
awareness and this was achieved through
a series of presentations to all
corporate managers and which was
followed up by a compulsory online
e-learning module for all staff at
and which enables uh staff to recognize
suspicious transactions and what they
should do if they do identify them the
completed module will automatically be
filed on everybody's personal records so
we do have a record of that in terms of
terms of training and excuse me I've
arranged with HR and OD that this module
will form part of the induction program
for all new employees
in line with the council's corporate
values we've also taken the opportunity
to remind staff of the council's
whistleblowing policy arrangements and
how we as an organization want to create
an open and supportive culture where
Staff feel comfortable in raising
concerns without fear of any
consequences of doing so
we've also used as a timely reminder to
both counselors yourselves and also
staff on our responsibilities around
gifts and hospitality
this will also include annual checks
around Declarations of interest and this
will actually form part of the ethical
work in the audit plan for next year and
the years to come
we've also used through our working
together newsletter best practice on how
to encrypt PDF documents to prevent
records being fraudulently altered we
have got an incident which we're
currently looking at where we think that
an outside person has tried to alter a a
document supposedly from ourselves and
that's something why we thought it would
be useful to have that best practice to
alert staff that there are other
controls to help those documents with
these more secure
we also continue to alert staff for the
national fraud bulletins which I get on
a regular basis and where is relevant
regarding internal controls we actually
go to the service areas where that might
be affected to ensure that those
controls are actually operating
effectively
council's shared revenues partnership
still continue to put out strong
messages about fraud both in the
publicity they sent out and also the
documents regarding council tax and
housing benefit claim forms
a member of my staff continues to attend
account for all webinars for example the
organized fraud and intelligence group
and again that's fed back to the
councils where we feel it's necessary to
do so where we might be exposed to any
risks
to help fraud across Suffolk generally
we have what's called a Suffolk counter
fraud group and a member of my staff
sits on that and again that's to discuss
local issues as well as National issues
and also share general knowledge and
training as well and that's a useful
forum for that
the council shared revenues partnership
continues to perform well and again is
once again recognized by the department
for working pensions in terms of how to
reduce fraud and error in housing
benefit payments and the work that
they've done and the outcomes are
contained within this report
moving on to fraud referrals reported
these are the ones that are reported to
the councils since the launch of our
fraud referral platform and customer
service assistant back in December baber
and mid-suffolk have received a total of
23 Ford referrals from the general
public these referrals have been
categorized with outcomes in the report
that's been presented to you
we're also take an active role in the
national fraud initiative work and
workers started investigating the
identified matches in the latest
exercise and these will be reported to
you later in the year once we've
actually done some further work and come
up with the outcomes of those
there's also a number of Grant payments
and again my member of Staff continues
to support What's called the business
sale within the council responsible for
the administration of these payments and
she's looking at the levels of assurance
that the funds to ensure that funds are
only paid to illegible businesses for
example and ensuring that appropriate
action is taken to recover any of those
funds that have been paid out due to
fraud or or error in their applications
so inclusion in conclusion sorry
um although the councils traditionally
encountered low levels of Fraud and
Corruption we nevertheless take it very
seriously and I think it's proportionate
in terms of the actions and the work
that we actually put across in terms of
taking reaction and proactive work
across the councils
so I'm comfortable with the levels of
resources that we have available to us
which just leaves me to take any
questions in terms of the report itself
thank you
uh on page 17
paragraph 3.19
where it mentions
single resident discounts on our council
tax this is I assume uh the final
sentence of paragraph 3.19 says the note
this is the overall total to be shared
between preceptors what is actually
meant by preceptors please
counselor so um if I take a step back
you'll see that
um that suffocated Council have provided
some funding for the SRP to undertake
this work and they actually have a
vested interest so the more that we can
save the better it is in terms of the
precepts that we had across to Suffolk
County Council so it's the money that we
pay back to them so there is a vested
interest in terms of us actually
reducing that and they benefit from
savings
probably because I'm only been here for
a year how does this year compare to
previous ones because clearly this is a
refreshingly low level but uh
how to compare
in terms of what we're finding it's it's
fairly comparable as I said
famous last words we tend to have low
levels of risk but that's not to say
that risks and fraud doesn't happen it's
we have to take a proportional view in
terms of the risk and exposure to the
councils in terms of anti-fault
interruption work that we do so with
more resources yes I could put more
resources into it but as we know there
are budgets and financial implications
associated with that so we have to take
a proportional approach but in terms of
what we're finding year on year it's not
too dissimilar and what in an Ideal
World we'd hope that that reduces as we
put more controls in place but
unfortunately in this
the economic climate that we're finding
ourselves in You could argue there's
probably more opportunities or
fraudsters are looking for more
opportunities because this scarce money
around at the moment so we need to
remain very Vigilant and hence why in
terms of the plan for next year I've
kept the same number of allocated days
to look at four counter fraud and
Corruption work
um thank you very much chair thank you
John for your report I've got three just
brief questions if I may
um one on the um
and he thought the raising money
laundering awareness work
um can you just confirm that all that
all employees have had the training and
also just how frequently that
that is if it's at near law biennial or
whatever it is
um secondly just with regards to fraud
referrals to the councils
um
the 23 fraud refers from the general
public is that high in comparison to
similar type councils
and then finally if you could just note
the um you know we've seen a lot in the
press as well about the covert grants
and the work with um Bayes if um there's
any update on that and when that work is
likely to be complete thank you very
much thank you
thank you councilor
um first question around money
laundering
um this is something that I had in the
plan for this year because I was acutely
aware that we hadn't really addressed
money laundering as rigorously as we
should have perhaps been done in the
past so hence why the presentations and
the e-learning module there is a tracker
on the e-learning module it is
compulsory and again I've got sanction
from our chief exec he was the person
that said I actually want everybody
because I was directing a corporate
manager level and above here said no
we'll have that all for all staff so in
terms of figures
I think last count it was 75 but it's
only the e-learning module is fairly new
and I think one of our employees from
the health uh sorry HR and LD is
monitoring the number of people that
have actually completed that and is
reporting back to my colleague so we can
ensure that by a certain date and we're
looking for the next month or two that
they've all undertaken that training so
and there will be refresher training at
a certain point so the important thing
is to get everybody signed up to have
evidence on their records as well and to
keep a track of those who don't and and
I will be sending a fairly current email
to their managers if they haven't
attended so that's being tracked as I
said there will be some follow-up
training
maybe in the next year or so depends how
many cases are well we're finding lots
of cases we're potentially many
laundries coming to our attention that
we might have to escalate that sooner
than later but um dare I say touch wood
we haven't had any cases this year of
money laundering for that your second
question on referrals again the actual
platform is new so it was first
introduced on in December prior to
December we were sharing a platform with
our colleagues from Suffolk County
Council
interestingly since we've developed our
own platform we've had an increase but I
don't know the figures from last year
they certainly weren't as high as as
they are now and you can see the results
and the outcomes of that and I suspect
that won't change but obviously next
year I'll be able to draw some
comparisons between obviously this year
and next year to give you a view of
whether it's increasing in terms of
those notifications referrals coming
through us or not in terms of the covet
update staff the the business grants Etc
that's continual that's ongoing all the
time at the moment we've got the Energy
payment as well and that's also another
source where we need to keep on top of
things so and my colleagues working with
as I said the the business sale so she's
one member of a small team about six
that are dealing with it
thank you very much um
on the money laundering it it does
strike me as a strange setup to have
every director
trained rather than one single champion
in the organization that it eventually
gets to but um have we got some form of
flowchart for
to carry out these like if the suspicion
of money laundering in a particular area
that we know that that will definitely
reach someone's senior with the with the
absolute full training
on money laundering
um yeah so yeah go for that one and then
I've got another one to ask thank you
um so I am the the council's money
laundering report well not the reporting
office behind the money laundering
officer
So within the policy of prevention of
financial crime policy that I'm
responsible for writing there is a
section on money laundering and it tells
you in terms of how to recognize
suspicious documents Etc when to
question and there is a process in terms
of reporting it through to me and
there's also clear instructions that if
they do suspect it it's on a need to
know basis so that's very very clear to
the individual they might have to go and
speak to their manager and the manager
would come to me but there is a um it
can't spread in terms of that knowledge
because there's a danger there could be
potential tip-offs and that and that's
the reason why it's on a need to know
basis so if there's any concerns it
would normally be flagged to their line
manager just to check whether their
views are shared then it would come to
me as the money laundering officer I
would then make a judgment in terms of
whether I think this is money laundering
or the further work needs to be done to
satisfy myself before I then have to go
through the due process of reporting
that and again there's quite a heavy
responsibility on me for that and I
actually can be prosecuted individually
if I don't take proper course of action
on money laundering so
it's taken extremely seriously and I
have to report back to the person who's
reporting it and telling them
in a summary of what action has been
taken
so it is taken so in terms of champion I
am the the champion however there's a
responsibility to all of us that's Chief
exec right down to the lowest grade to
be aware of money laundering regulations
and hence why Arthur was very keen to
have all staff undertake
so I'm very happy with that I think that
sounds like a really good way to deal
with it
um the other thing was this um issue of
encryption in PDFs
um
uh well where does so we've got the it
the um
the guys in it in the in the council and
um I know they're doing a huge amount of
work to prevent malware and all all the
kind of things that this would obviously
affect this report where do those guys
fit in with you you know um as the
internal audit
um manager how how do you work with
those I.T guys to make sure that they're
giving us exactly what we need to to
deal with the um the threats yeah so I
have a close relationship with Matt
Harding who's our corporate manager
responsible for RIT so we regularly talk
you'll also I'm not sure if members get
this so pardon apologies if it's wrong
but I know certainly staff get stuff
through from Suffolk County Council as
well because obviously we share their
platforms so in terms of stuff that's
coming through to us there are obviously
firewalls Etc that are undertaken as
part of the annual governance statement
as well I get a statement from Matt
Hardy to the fact of a roundabout
controls in place and the governance
Arrangements around ICT arrangements so
we do work closely and again within our
audits we take a holistic approach
around ICT stuff we're not experts and I
don't pretend we are experts at all so
but we take out a relatively low level
in terms of systems Administration who
has passwords is their separation of
Duties and that sort of stuff we also
have our external audit Partners here
who have recently undertaken an audit on
cyber security for example because they
have the expertise to do it and
unfortunately that came out in terms of
the outcomes as reasonable Assurance so
we do work closely with Matt and also
within our own internal audit team
yes thank you Chad
um John really good paper
um it shows that we are doing what we
meant to do one thing that keeps coming
out
is not our primary role to to manage
fraud but it is our role to instruct
others to do so and I've just sort of
wondered I find that very difficult to
be honest because um
apart from training that councilman
myself attended at the beginning we
haven't had a lot of training
I take on board that we've had periods
of lockdown and things and it's been
very difficult but
I think just trying to guide things into
the next Council maybe
um I certainly think councilors who sit
on this committee should have sight of
the risk register so we're all aware of
what the risks might be I would not have
thought money laundering was something
that we might be a victim of but
obviously some think so or maybe James
has just been watching the gold on the
Telly a bit too much you know
but it obviously is a thing and I'm
thinking um are we are we capable of
managing this I think perhaps we need a
bit more guidance and training because
apart from the obvious ones I don't
think I could name all the risks of
fraud that we might um be the victim of
so it's a steer for the future really
maybe we could um you know know a bit
more and do a bit better
yeah I think councilor it's quite an
interesting and a valid question to ask
um I relinquish responsibility for risk
as you know that's now being taken over
by another corporate manager under a set
of disciplines
[Music]
without wishing to step on anybody's
toes you have a right to see that risk
register
and perhaps
I might
suggest you do to be honest you do need
to have an appreciation of risks whether
it's
um related to fraud count fraud and work
or not you do need to have sight of that
and you need to have an assurance that
those risks are being well managed and
there are proper mitigations to reduce
the risk so but I think in terms of that
that's something for you as a committee
to take forward and ask the relevant
officers
it'd be wrong of me to to say yes
because I'm not responsible for the risk
register as such but we all in this room
have a responsibility to to manage risks
you know when you're out on site
read the challenge you know to us as
officers so I think it is important but
that's my view it might not be shared by
others but that's something I think you
can pursue through the relevant offices
that are responsible now for risk
management per se you will get reports
particularly on the Strategic policy for
risk management strategy
um
as I know you have done in the past and
register but there's no reason why you
can't answer it
thank you chair just through you chair
just just to add a bit to that so as a
committee you you're here to look at the
the process for managing that risk
the process that you want to is it
adequate does it do what it needs to do
or testing in terms of the money and
ordering regulation is quite right it's
um Mr
mlr is John
there's a process in place the process
is all about training everyone in the
authority to to identify money
laundering and then at the level where
money comes into the organization and
I'll give you an example a housing
officer who's dealing with the right to
buy sale
or a legal legal somebody illegal who's
dealing with the right to buy sale
That's a classic money laundering
scenario where you've got a large amount
of money coming into the council and so
you put in place a process first things
first identify potentials and that's not
just that the processes should identify
where money laundering could be an issue
and the process identifies it by saying
to all those in the council who are
responsible for any income or outgoings
to be vigilant to be trained and to
understand what money laundering is
there is a there is a list of those type
of things and like you I don't know
every single scenario
that the authority could be faced with
but the basic principle is is that if
there's money coming into the authority
we want to know what what the source of
it is and that's kind of the basic
principle that needs to be instilled in
on all the offices and in all the
processes that we have
yes I think chairman um I hear what the
officers say but my fear is that there
is a danger that that we can't think of
you say or we're not aware of so um I
think if it was set out a bit more
formally with some training
um it would be good for the next um
joint audit and standards I mean who
could be a completely new one we could
have 10 new people here
um and this is difficult it takes a
couple of years just to sort of um
realize what you're really doing this
message is jazz so um
um I think that's something I would like
to um
you have to see going forward to be
honest if that can be um if that can be
set up and um gifty talked about sort of
the right to buy on 328 that says
there's no right to buy concerns but
when we looked at this before I remember
there was one um I think it was refused
because it was felt the money came from
elsewhere if um now my question on that
is is it was it resolved satisfactorily
or or was it allowed how did that one
turn out just just for my own sort of
information as something that we talked
about previously
yeah in this particular instance
um I reported it through the proper
channels
um and yes the application was refused
and as part of my role is to gain as
much evidence as we could and there was
no conclusive proof
where that money was coming from so we
challenged and continued to challenge
they couldn't provide suitable answers
so we then refused the application and
strange enough it went away but having
said that we then as part of my role I
had then reported it to the National
Crime office which I am required to do
the outcome of that I don't hear
so I'm in terms of my role
we had satisfied ourselves from a
council's point of view that we weren't
happy with the application and the the
lack of evidence to support where that
money had come from and often where you
do get
issues is particularly where money is
coming from abroad and all the
transactions and sporting documentation
are in a different language and you have
to then actually translate it
it's still a little bit dubious so we
will often ask we did have in the past
asked for someone with probably greater
knowledge and another authority to just
have a look at that to make sure that
our reasoning was Secure and in this
instance yes they fully backed what we
were trying to do and we were quite
right not to release the asset
effectively because that's what it is
to the applicant um
that application was withdrawn but in
terms of the outcome I don't know
whether they were then asked to provide
evidence to another Authority
um but in this instance for this year
there haven't actually been any
where
particularly with right to buy where it
is most prevalent if it's going to
happen just to give you a couple of
other examples where it can happen is
where on council tax for example on
business rates perhaps more where
as in the current year but for
subsequent years as well and that money
is in sort of like tens of thousands of
pounds you would then question why would
you want to do that um
upon and then would be investigated
because that's
so that's just perhaps another example
of where money laundering could be
targeted to make payments in advance
using cash
John um that was what I wanted to know
so it is working I think we should be um
quite proud of that thank you chair
it's funny um John sort of talked to a
lot of what I was going to say I was
going to say um if we're talking about
right to buy we have solicitors involved
conveyancing solicitors which will be
aware of money laundering and trained
and everything but on the smaller level
but you've just actually gone into that
when when people are paying cash on a
smaller level do we have powers to look
at source of funds at that level or do
we just report it onto
um what we would do in this case we
don't have a trained process of crime
officer but we have one in a neighboring
Authority that we would actually then
ask them to undertake that investigation
on our behalf
um obviously there's a small cost
involved
um but when you're talking about crime
what price do you put on crime and if
there's a legitimate case to be answered
then that's referred to them and then
would be referred to the police in the
normal fashion
um
some people still um do use cash to pay
bills and things and you know it's it's
obviously to a certain level that it
would start to um ring alarm Bells
um
yeah no that's that's good that's really
good to hear
um Council of benefits or not benefits
sorry
um
when when gifts are given in
Declarations of gifts you said that
we're going to annually look at
that and and what form will that be in
and I know Declarations of Interest need
to be updated regularly but are we are
we going to do something outside of that
certainly we like us and Hospitality for
example I mean the the danger here is we
only know what we know so if you don't
tell us
um there's very little we can perhaps do
unless somebody decides to shop
um but what we're trying to do at the
moment we recognize that there's
probably a level of inconsistency across
the councils at the moment in terms of
gifts and hospitality
we're a little bit aggravated we have a
register a manual register and I want
that to be electronicized so and I'm
talking with Jan Robertson and her team
of using modern.gov as a potential
software that we can have prescribed
documents that can be completed by
staff I'm talking about in this case
obviously members you also have your own
rules in terms of your code of conduct
that you need to declare give some
hospitality and some Declarations of
Interest which you do we're just trying
to raise awareness particularly from an
internal point of view with staff to
make sure there's a consistent approach
right across the organization
particularly within those areas so what
we're trying to do is putting in hard
and fast rules
and cement those for this year next year
but also take annual looks at those
registers to make sure gifts and
hospitalities are being correctly dealt
with and as I said the caveat is we only
know what we know
but those that we do know we want to
make sure that they're dealt with
properly
in terms of the Declarations of interest
for officers again that should be an
annual
that should be an annual check signed
off by the individual member of staff
and their line manager
to make sure that there is impartiality
and there aren't any conflicts of
interest either within them within the
work they do or with a working partner
close relationship Etc so they're in all
areas that we would consider
yeah because I think I'm
a review is quite necessarily with the
decorators of interest because it's very
easy for a counselor to fill them out
and then not look at them in the in a
four-year term but with a review uh if
you're almost um changing just changing
the date reviewed on them it's a lot
it's uh it's a lot easier for a
counselor to have that not that I think
that that goes on at all another no
experience of that going on but I do um
oh I forgot and ignorance is not a a
good um
you know the reason to um to not fill
out things like that and I think timely
reminders just help all of us you know
not just you as counselors but also as
the staff as well as you said it's easy
to forget something you know quite
innocently
um yeah
and the last thing sorry that I wanted
to talk about is um whistleblowing
within different departments
um how do we handle that how do we make
sure that people can
blow whistles freely
um without the risk of
you know all the all the problems
associated with that in a large
organization
and I think I mean again that's a very
valid point I think it comes down to the
council's core values of being open and
transparent and honesty as I said within
my report we've issued a statement on
the working together we use that as just
an opportunity again to stay in line
with our values you know if you do have
concerns then there's proper channels
and again the whistleblowing policy was
is in within the prevention of financial
crime policy that I'm responsible for so
um and there are three people generally
that they will come to normally it will
come to me first if they if a person's
got General concerns
the monitoring officer is another one
and also the section 151 officer
um so if they had concerns that they
couldn't approach their manager they
would then come to normally as I said
first point of call would normally be me
um to deal with those and those are
treated in confidence we need to be
careful they're not malicious as well
and that's the other flip side that
someone hasn't got a bit of an extra
grind but you take each case on face
value and again
um the assurances that I provide that
person would be yes we would protect you
if you felt that there was a case and
they shouldn't feel
um that they're going to be consequences
as a result
because I wouldn't be naming them
we've got to that stage the person the
whistleblowers come to you they've
reported something's not been done
properly and it's been covered up maybe
um where where do you go with it then
you've um you've got that information
you've got to obviously protect the
person The Whistleblower but how where
do you go then do you
I would then investigate that and look
at the evidence that has been provided
to me in trying to justify whether
there's a strong case or not I would do
some form of Investigation even if it
was light touch if I thought there
wasn't anything there and the evidence
wasn't there to support it if I felt
there was some issues that needed to be
addressed I would at some point
obviously if there is a disciplinary
then I would have to liaise with
somebody from HR and IT probably read
Suzanne Hughes the chief officer or the
head of
HR and also as part of the procedure
I would provide a summary back to the
Whistleblower in terms of what actions
being taken but that might have to be
suppressed if there was there were
sensitive issues surrounding that area
but they would get a report back to them
in terms of the actions that have been
taken
how do you deal with the access to that
department if you so you need to go into
the department and find out if
something's
being signed off that's not being done
or something for instance
um how can you just walk into the
department and say I've come to to audit
giving the Trade Secrets away huh yeah
sorry yeah no we might have to go into
play session actually but um whatever
you provide you a level of assurance
there are ways and means that I can
access information and um
my badge allows me to do that okay
um without going into details
um in terms of information that I
require I can get that information
squeaky or not
let's see if it's we're still playing it
would be done streetly and I can find a
way of actually looking at areas of work
without alerting maybe people that I I
not I don't need to be alerted to
thank you very much indeed for your
report John I think it's really
excellent I'm really pleased about the
points that have been made with regard
to training and also to the money
laundering aspect because money
laundering is on the increase
generally for what we hear and the thing
that particularly I was thinking about
John
with the training yes all the staff are
having the training would it be helpful
for future members of the jsac committee
to be given a members briefing on money
laundering because it's such an
important subject and I think it'd be
quite good to have a more awareness of
it the reason I raise that as in a
former life I was a job center plus
fraud manager and I had to do a
professional in security course for
managers
and my teams had to do just a normal
pins course and that did include money
laundering and it's a very complex
subject
and I think the the point made a better
flow chart and everything and I just
think that it would be very very useful
for new councilors to have a background
just to see what you are looking at that
type of thing and to be aware of it I
think that's really really important
what I'll try and do chair is as I said
we've got this e-learning module I will
speak to the people that have set that
up and see if I can extend it to
um if we do it from after may that be as
efficient so I see if I can have your
names
um to to that list so you can at least
have cited it in the meantime I can send
you these slides that I sent to All
corporate managers so that will also
give you a bit of flavor of money
laundering generally and then hopefully
you can have that supplemented by the
e-learning module if that's um you would
like you can sort that out I think
that'd be really helpful actually if we
could see those guys I appreciate that
thank you do you have any further
questions okay sorry bro please oh sorry
I was a comment I wasn't sure if we were
on to comments at the moment well no it
was officially on my script because it
actually makes a debate
um but I'm happy to go back to debate
now that that's right I was just going
to follow up by me because I kind of
think um
uh with regards to kind of training and
information that we need to see and
information on money laundering and so
on and further to the um monitoring
officers comments I kind of think we we
should be very careful of not going too
much into detail because that's what we
should be trusting the officers to do
and that's their that's their
responsibility our responsibility is to
oversee that and ensure that training is
in place and that the processes are in
place and I think if you started
bombarding
um members with very specific
information and detail about space
specific areas of work then we risk kind
of getting too much involved in the
detail and actually not being able to to
see The Wider picture and if you were
you know a training program probably
last for a fortnight if you were going
to go into that detail of each aspect so
I just sort of note of caution that we
do need uh you know I've raised training
a lot in this committee
um because I think it's something that
we've not um that's not sufficient
um to be honest and um I and I think
that there have been those subjects have
been raised today should be part of that
but I would just say a note of caution
just to not go into too much detail
because I think otherwise you would risk
um putting people off actually really
understanding what their role is on this
committee and their role as members but
I fully support the need for for a
decent um training but also I think it's
something that we should use as a um
whether it's LGA training so it's
actually not you know we're not asking
officers to create
training program
um certainly for baber and mid-suffolk
but we have I'm sure there are plenty of
types of training for for these types of
committees that we can kind of use thank
you chair
I do take a point on that and I think my
thought was not a really sort of
in-depth training but just to make
people aware and I think perhaps the
slides that John was talking about may
be the solution in that particular
instance
yeah just very quickly Joe the same
subject I think the new Committee just
needs um broad Rush awareness training
of
are there is to look at basically just
to help them from the from day one and
and I think it it probably has been
minuted but I think it ought to be
um a steer for the new Jac and also um
the opportunity to look at the risk
register which I think also we should
have um have sight of early on
that's that's basically it
should be noted
um can I have a proposal and a second of
please
came to the custard and councilor Norris
I know I know ask the governor's office
to go to the phone please thank you
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
whichever is 90 weights for that's
unanimous as carried
the next item is item 8 Jac 2147 the
internal audit plan for 23 24 and I
would like once again to invite the
corporate manager for internal audit Jon
Snow to introduce the report to the
committee thank you John
thank you
so the report the purpose of this report
in front of you is mainly to provide you
with members of uh the audit plan for
next year
which details the the scope of the
audits to be undertaken and the
corporate activities that will be
supported through the work of the team
during the year
the plan has been developed to ensure it
delivers against the public sector
internal audit standards and covers the
following activities
governance processes ethical values
Information Technology risk management
and fraud management
so the planning process also recognizes
that the the councils are still trying
or continued striving to improve
services and use Innovative approaches
in delivering services against
what is a basically a backdrop of
reducing funds
um and therefore I've directed the
resources using a risk-based approach to
maximize the effectiveness of internal
controls across service areas
the construction of the audit plan has
been developed to support both the
annual governance statement which comes
to to this committee and also to look at
the and support the council's key
strategic themes
in developing the plan
um I've just listed here some of the
areas that I will consider in as part of
that development process and that is to
again review the council's Strategic
priorities contained in the corporate
plan and how these outcomes that support
them the significant and operational
risk registers
also engagement with Senior Management
to identify Management's views of the
forthcoming Year's risks again linked to
the corporate plan and delivery programs
and again to provide Assurance around
those
also consideration of the 23-24 budget
and here I'm looking at the to evaluate
the levels of income that we generate
areas of expenditure the value of the
assets and basically the volume of
transactions that are going through our
books
also I'm Keen to understand about the
past history of the audit work that
we've undertaken again that's to look at
past order opinions and the
recommendations that have been made and
implemented also looking around holistic
approaches around again talking about
the fraud risks and the values and the
complexities around transactions across
the piece
they also look at the three lines of
Defense in terms of the control
insurance so we're looking at sound
Management in front of Frontline
operations looking at the oversight of
management activity within each
professional framework and also looking
at the external review by independent
Assurance providers and also that
includes internal audit in that third
line of defense
the internal audit plan again will
continue to be resolved from existing
staff and also from our external audit
partner and again this Arrangement still
allows a direct internal provision plus
the commission of external skills and
capacity and provides a blend of
resources from within the councils and
from the external partner Services
themselves
you'll see that see in terms of the plan
the number of days is 535 old days
proposed in the audit plan and this is
structured to reflect the uh the audit
disciplines to be undertaken to support
delivery the governance and professional
framework
uh the resources committed to each
category is annotated in the detailed
planning Annex a and it's summarized
within appendix a
intention as far as it's possible that
these proposed audits within the plan
will be undertaken however I'm very
viable and recognized that the plan
needs to be flexible to respond to
changing circumstances or emerging risks
throughout that year so in effect the
plan is a form of statement of a tent
the plan as presented at Annex a
represents what my current views of how
audit resources can be most effectively
used where significant deviations to
that plan are required then these were
reported to Senior Management and also
back to this committee as appropriate
so in conclusion I'm satisfied at the
level of mix and of resources together
with the areas covered in the plan will
enable me to provide an annual internal
audit opinion at the end of the year
which again I present to you
um and at this point and apologize if
I'm going to embarrass two two members
here but um I would like to advise the
committee
um of the results of our recent external
quality assessment of the audit function
uh this was against the public sector
internal audit standards that were
carried out last month I'm waiting for
the final report to be issued but have
been advised by the external assessor
that the internal order function
conforms fully with the standards and
there were no areas of non-compliance
this is a really pleasing result and I
think of reflection of the work that we
undertake across the councils and again
I was going to apologize here but I'd
also like to personally thank councilors
Muller and harun because you guys were
part of that assessment and you were
interviewed by the external assessor so
obviously you said the right things as
well so many gratitudes do you both on
that front
um
there's no really additional audit rated
issues at this stage to report you so
again I'm just happy to take questions
um
we
um we've obviously got a bit in there
for um for um Building Services
um and we we had an issue with gas
safety checks not being completed and it
was something that we didn't
actually find out about until there's a
quite a large number were being um were
were not checked and not signed off
um
where does that put us in in them from
an audit point of view is this anything
we've learned from that or
is are we going to make any changes to
um adapt for that
um because it's all it's a very hard
thing because if things are getting
signed off
um not that I know that's exactly what
was happening here but um it's very it's
very hard to go down the next layer and
find out what's going on so I just
wonder what your views were on Lessons
Learned From that maybe what we're gonna
what we can do in the future maybe to
make sure that doesn't happen again
please
if I give a short response and I think
if D would also like to respond as well
so my very quick answer this is an
ongoing exercise at the moment so we've
self-regulated so we recognize that
we're a problem so rather than trying
not necessarily to hide it and keep it
in-house we've actually gone to the
regulators and saying there are some
issues okay that's an ongoing exercise
and we have got Consultants coming in to
address those issues there a number of
days you'll see within the plan to look
at this at a later stage so we will wait
and turn in in terms of what their
findings and recommendations are and
then I've spoken to the director of
housing or we would do a health check
almost
map in terms of what was recommended how
they're being implemented and where are
we now and obviously so it has been
flagged up and In fairness the director
of housing has fully accepted that and
that's why there are a number of audit
days within the plan to look at that
area and other areas within within that
service I'll hand over to IFD
just to say as a senior leadership team
we we have a site of the the risk
register and how how the um getting
how the gas inspections are taking place
as well as the electrical inspections
on the back of that there are because
what we've got to we've got to realize
is that these are these are our
properties these are the council
these are our tenants who aren't
allowing us to go into the property to
do the gas inspection
so we're actually taking out injunctions
against those who will not let us go
into their properties and there's a
can't give you the figures off the top
of my head but there are a number there
are only a couple that have actually got
through the system because a bit of
Batman got caught but that's that's
where that's where we are so
in terms of senior leadership team we've
got almost like a a weekly
weekly to two weekly oversight of how
those figures are going it's being
heavily monitored it is being reported
um I'm just trying to remember what the
what the reporting structure is it
doesn't come here
but it does go to uh to other to other
parts of the council
and and it and they're all checked
against a plan it just keeps coming up
time and time again so it's very
encouraging to me because I I see it in
different various places
falling off the radar it's a very
important thing for the council to we've
reported ourselves and we dubbed
ourselves in because it was the right
thing to do
we put in place the measures to deal
with it and we're taking extremely
seriously I mean that's that's the
bottom line really
that up is the are these um is that type
of thing ever covered by audit so that
that would be under the um scope of the
audit to um to look into that because um
it does and I know that a huge amount is
going on and um the um and I sympathize
because yeah a lot of it was caused by
people refusing and if someone won't let
you in your in their house you can't do
it but it's just to
detect it and I feel that maybe it was
it it wasn't detected that early so
could is it possible to do that as part
of this audit to look into that
um
as as I've mentioned we we've got a
number of days for the plan next year
there is no point in internal audit
going in while the Consultants are in
doing their their work because we will
probably come to similar conclusions so
we're waiting so rather than duplicating
work quite frankly and telling the
director of housing what they already
know we're waiting for those results
um I've also I'm aware that probably the
regulator will be keeping watch rely on
us for for a whole year probably to make
sure that we are compliant but we will
wait until the Consultants have done
their pieces of work to look at what
recommendations they are making and as I
said there's going to be a period of
embedment and then we would come in and
do a health check is one for a bed of a
word that we
that would form part of my report and
then the summary of those findings would
then come back to you in the normal
course of action
um thank you chair and thank you John
for your report
um a couple of quick points and then a
longer question
um
with the point that um cancer Cassens
just raised um that was to do with the
social housing regulator and other
councils picked this up 18 months ago
so I don't know where I don't think that
would have
I don't know where that would have been
picked up because it wouldn't have been
picked up in a Building Services audit
we should have been picked up
um in another
um
you know at another level
um because Norwich City Council for
example we're looking at this this work
18 months ago so you know it's why we
took so long to do it I'm not quite sure
but the the other quick point is the is
on the bottom of page 32 refer to
program boards and a um
looking at that and I just wanted to
just
I'm not quite sure if the language is
right because it's saying um provide the
councils with an interface through which
members will at program level hold
officers to account my understanding is
that's only cabinet members that are on
those program boards it's not
um
other members so members per se
um so um I might be corrected on that
but um and I know there's some working
groups but I'm just you know I just
think just wanted to be clear about the
language if that's
um but if I'm wrong I'm happy to be
corrected
um but my main point really is on
paragraph two 5.2
um just with regards to
um
um internal or on our performance
um and um
Performance Management framework
um
and I just wondered because one of the
things that's been raised in the past is
actually
um relating the Performance Management
framework with the financial
um with the finances and financial
objectives and I'm matching the matching
the two together and secondly not just
reporting on things that are going well
but reporting on things that aren't that
need Improvement and I just would like a
view on how internal audit
um
how an internal audit plan would kind of
work through that thank you very much
thank you chair
yeah thank you councilor um in terms of
the Performance Management framework
we've not really looked at that in any
great detail in the past hence why I've
put it in for for next year
um we've got a fairly new
um
corporate manager or she's an interim
but in terms of the performance
management team we've now got a
relatively new team so it's really good
for me to then touch base with these
guys in terms of making a real
difference but you're quite right the
the emphasis uh in terms in terms of
Performance Management the framework and
providing relative reports is to link in
performance with financial implications
but also risk as well so the idea was
those three disciplines were sort of
like mashed together to provide a very
meaningful report particularly to to
members uh for for their attention if
you like so what we're looking at is
that framework in terms of the kpis that
have formally agreed by yourselves how
are they actually managed how are they
reported did you say is it everything
that's reported is exception reporting
do you want to know about other areas so
it's looking at how robust that
framework is and does it meet
expectations I suppose certainly from an
organizational point of view but also
from you as from counselors whether
you're getting that right level of
information because in the past if I'm
honest sometimes the performance reports
a bit
urged and not very interesting and
really they need to be livened up a
little bit and actually focus on some of
the real issues that you need to be
aware of and how to dress and release
insurance from offices that we are on
top of those and what those outcomes are
and they're being met so it's that whole
structure in terms of the kpis that are
agreed in terms of the outputs and
outcomes as a result of that
um if I could come back on that um at
what level do you feel that there will
be member involvement in that um
in that order in terms of kind of
um
you know how how we as a broad group of
of counselors would expect to see
performance measure the financial uh um
implications of that
um and as well as you say the risk on
that thank you yeah thank you cancer I
think what we would tend to do is I said
I haven't briefed it out yet for next
year but I think the expectation was
what would be the process so how do kpis
come about what's that level of
Engagement and consultation is it with a
few or is it with the many
um and so it's just trying to establish
what that process is flowchart it and
establish whether everybody is actually
getting a the right level of information
and input that they need to actually
move those forwards but um again I'll
have to scope that out obviously with
the performance manager as well
thank you chair
um
yes obviously produced a very clear and
thorough report
well done to yourself and your team uh
got to your pie chart
on page 29 and I got very very excited
then I went for the details and I became
very disappointed
on the subject of environment
because obviously with a certain
political color
the environment means one thing and
clearly at the present time with with
your audit team it means something
a very specific about contracts
I think I know that we have a strategic
plan that says we get to Net Zero by
yet nowhere in the documents do I see
any reference to that as a strategic
Target
I'm not looking to start a revolution
which is probably
however last week the UN pointed out
that we needed to change things rapidly
so could I suggest that we start by
maybe a small
inclusion or something to do with carbon
footprint and maybe
taking measurements of how much fuel we
use across our organization
whether it be for cars or Heating
so just a small start once one item
to help us get to where we want to get
to as an organization
yeah and I certainly take your point
what I would say is well
it was last year we did some work around
climate change
um so there was a big piece of work on
that it's quite specialized in terms of
the knowledge base and as you probably
know all in two orders which I could try
all tradesmaster have none
um so it would be something that if we
would consider later on that would
probably be looking at more specialized
pieces of work to get down to the
nitty-gritty stuff in terms of what
we're achieving but there is an action
plan isn't there
in terms of what we're trying to achieve
in terms of climate change as a yeah
no that's fine yeah
that's right
my when I looked at the action plan it
had a wonderful
broad-ranging statements but very little
detail
which I can understand when it was
written three years ago you know we're
three years into this with seven to go
as an organization
coming into it new and being aware of
what other organizations are outside of
this room are doing
sure away from my responsibilities that
you may want to speak to the director in
terms of that action plan and where we
are with that action plan and again
you're very entitled to do so because
with the action plan obviously they're
going to be monitoring it so they'll be
hopefully be able to give you a sort of
a current state of play as there's
nothing per se within the audit plan for
next year but that's not to say that
this won't be raised again and if there
are any emerging risks then don't forget
the internal audit plan is all based
around risk is there some emerging risks
either nationally that has an impact at
a local level then certainly we can
raise that I can raise that with the
director or the director can come to me
and say look we might need to focus on
this and again coming back to the audit
plan it is flexible
so if there's emerging risk something
else will get dropped off that list so
it is risk-based and prioritized in that
sense
yes thank you care
um yes I was going to talk about that
before Austin did and um
not as what has been covered um I think
I'm finding that four percent spent on
environmental um
issues is probably not the right balance
because we do do a lot with the biofilms
and things like that and but I do feel
we should be um
doing more
um and I take what John said about
reporting that to another place but then
I turned over the page and um
I see part of uh function in order is to
see we get the best price for things
um item forge on fees and charges it
seems that um we or you are tasked with
getting the best price for things I
presume that is correct and
um stop me there if I'm on the wrong
track please do no no in terms of fees
and charges what we're looking at in
terms of the incomes the the various
income streams
um to make sure that our fees and
charges are perhaps constant with other
local authorities that we're not under
charging or we're not over charging so
it's a sense that in the current climate
are we charging the correct fees or are
we underselling ourselves are we missing
a trick is there any other areas of
services that we provide that we could
charge for but we don't and as you know
that we are very much stretched for cash
so it's looking at those areas to make
sure that those fees and charges are fit
for purpose and we're not we're
maximizing what we can without a huge
impact on obviously the consumer so
there's a balance obviously without but
that's the area of audit that we're
trying to look at that they are
regularly looked at and there is some
research that says that is the correct
charge now it might be through
legislation that we can't charge anymore
but there may be some discrete areas
where we could charge more but we don't
it's just trying to maximize income
income streams
yeah well I think actually what I was
going to say is covered perfectly by
what um you've just said and it's an
environmental issue as well
uh many years back along with another we
um highlighted the need
for solar panels on Council house roofs
for which we get an income but I think
with the way things have panned out the
way things have moved on
I think it was a fixed term deal from
memory
um probably about four p a unit
which I think now in today's age is not
the best we can do
I'm also mindful that we're part of the
Suffolk partnership
energy from waste where all our black
been waste instead of going to landfill
it goes to all the energy from weight
plus a plant we're not advised to call
it an incinerator are we because it
doesn't sound as good but um for that I
think we get 6p a unit
now my point is that when we all go from
here and put the kettle on and have a
cup of tea to recover
we're paying 38 per unit
and my point is everybody that as things
have moved on that surely is not the
best we can do
um in our role can we ask that some of
these contracts I know that the council
has several panels was a fixed contract
but that was
10 years ago
there must be some scope for doing
better on some of these schemes and the
fees that we're charging or just being
given
it's a big environmental issue because
the less people are paid for what they
do
in the new environmental World they
won't do it so there are big issues here
for the council and possibly
um bigger incomes that could be had in a
positive way so
that is a question it's a statement
we could be doing more we should be
doing more and the people we sell
the energy to shouldn't be getting away
with it in that way
and maybe that's something that the
procurement team can look at along with
the managers that oversay the actual
contracts themselves
just going to move into debate
we don't have to but if you don't say
don't have one I just didn't know if
there was a debate
kick off the debate
it's not much of a debate really I just
wanted to um thank John Snell I've heard
everything he's
um done this term with the order it's
it's an incredibly complicated process
you've got to know so much about so many
different aspects of the council and the
organization is absolutely huge there's
so many different things going on and it
absolutely
um impressively so much that the amount
of information that he deals with to
create these reports and the competence
of them so I just wanted to say thank
you very much and um yeah um it's a it's
a really good
yeah it's a really good um plan you know
um paper as always and um yeah thank you
I don't I don't really have anything to
debate because I think it's it does
exactly what it should do
and and chair I will second that as well
um yes this coach here um John has been
brilliant and sorry if I give you a bad
time sometimes you know
I just like to confirm my thanks for
directing my energies so I know what to
do next thank you
yes I I too would like to thank John and
his team for all the extra work that
you've done
um in this Administration over the last
four years been really appreciated and
you know we thank you for the detailed
papers and the really good quality of
the papers as well so thank you John
that's that's really good thank you
it is actually BeNaughty but as I said
earlier myself and and my co-chair Kate
I said we would vote on this the actual
recommendation is that the content of
this internal reported by appendix a be
noted
um could I have a proposal in a second
to place Council Harrod and then
counselor
thank you chair that let us know in
progress
foreign
thank you very much indeed Beth and I
shall move on to the next item on the
agenda which is item nine
hang on um Jac 2143 complaints
monitoring report and I would like to
invite the monitoring officer to
introduce the report to the committee
Please Mr Ali yes
yes thank you chair this is an
information report for noting
um it's to do with the an update on the
number of code of conduct complaints
that have come in since the uh since the
last time it's reported to this
committee so from the 18th of January
2023 to the 7th of March 2023
and the baby District Council area we've
had 13 complaints so it's 13 coded
combat complaints
um that's relating to
um six District councilors
several of those complaints against
Parish councilors so seven town or
Parish councilors
in terms of complaints upheld some are
still going through the process because
they've only just come in uh there have
been no findings of breach in relation
to two of those so we've still got 11
outstanding and they're in various
stages at the moment what we do with
regards to uh code of conduct complaints
is that the first step is that there's
an initial assessment
it then goes off to uh the the subject
member
the subject of the complaint is then
asked for an explanation or for
information or comment
that then goes to comes back and then
goes to the independent person
um and the independent person on the
monitor officer then come to a
conclusion as to whether or not it's to
proceed to investigation or whether or
not there's some other local Remedy or
whether it's not to proceed at all so
that's where we are with those those 11
at the moment thank you
oh yes I should have said
um
mid-servic have zero complaints that are
coming in that time period
that's basically just for noting so
we'll move on to item nine which is Jac
2144 which is the forward plan and
please note that the statement of
accounts in order to report 2223 should
read statement of account in order to
report 20
21 do members have any comments at all
please
thank you very much that again is just
for noting
um so that actually concludes this
meeting and the next joint audit and
standards committee meeting will be on
Monday the 31st of July 2023 at 10 30
a.m but before we finish as this is the
last jsac Committee of this term I would
like to thank my co-chair councilor
hiring for his work and I'd like to
thank members of the committee for all
the very very good questions we've asked
over the four years and obviously our
colleagues if the Ali and John snails
are all their work and obviously the
officers as well the committee class so
thank you very much indeed for all your
hard work and I will now close the
meeting at 15 20. thank you very much
everybody
thank you